[Music]
hey legal eagles D James Stone here
teaching you how to think like a lawyer
last week we covered the first half of
Liar Liar today we're covering the
second half including the entire divorce
trial so let's dig in
remember to like and subscribe and be
sure to comment in the form of an
objection I'll either sustain or
overrule it and while you're there let
me know what movie or TV show I should
do next and stick around until the end
when I give Liar Liar a grade for legal
realism so without further ado let's dig
in to the second half of Liar Liar
[Music]
that is not what courtroom bathrooms
look like is way too nice why are all
these people in this Court this is a
random family divorce there's no reason
all those people should be there from
March 6 through June 12 I serve a
Lissa's Cole at the behest of mr. Cole
during that period I noted that mr. Cole
left each day between 7:40 and 7:50
thereafter mrs. Cole would frequently
have a male visitor arrive and stay from
1 to 4 hours so at this point I think
Fletcher read Jim Carrey's character
should probably be objecting there are a
couple issues here I don't know if they
win the day but they're probably worth
objecting to number 1 California has
some really strong invasion of privacy
laws so this investigator is conceivably
invading the privacy of mrs. Cole
presumably what is going on in her own
residence inside of her own bedroom I
don't know if that creates an
evidentiary burden to bring this
evidence in and therefore it would be
unlawful to bring this kind of evidence
into their divorce proceedings that
doesn't seem like it would carry the day
because I'm sure that there are many
instances of private investigators
actually taking the stand in providing
exactly this kind of evidence in a
wedding proceeding to show adultery in a
violation of the prenuptial agreement
but as a putative Lee experienced trial
lawyer
Fletcher Reed really should be breaking
up the flow to prevent the private
detective from getting into a rhythm and
getting his entire story out and showing
all of presumably the bad evidence it's
about to come out I was able to take
some photographs of the male visitor I
see I don't know what the attorney has
just done here she has handed the
photographs from the witness to the
judge without laying the foundation
that's necessary a photograph needs to
have foundation laid before you can
bring it into court to bring it into
evidence and if you don't bring it into
evidence then it's as if the photograph
never existed because the judge can only
take things into consideration that
actually came into evidence so she needs
to lay the foundation that
this person took those photographs that
they reflect the scene accurately when
he took those photographs and they're a
fair and accurate representation of what
actually happened so those are all
evidentiary hurdles that this witness
must establish and overcome in order for
these pictures to be entered into
evidence and the attorney just can't
pick them up and then hand them over to
the judge that just it doesn't happen
you slowly enter them into evidence
after you've laid the appropriate
foundation Your Honor as you are aware
under the terms of the prenuptial
agreement if mrs. Cole commits adultery
she is entitled to nothing with your
permission we'd like to play the
following tape recording No okay so
there are a lot of problems with what
just happened in court in order to
establish that this witness has the
personal knowledge of what happened
between mrs. Cole and her gentleman
callers the the lawyer has to establish
that he has some reason for this
personal knowledge in other words he has
some basis to be able to opine as to
what was going on and he actually took a
step back and said the wrong thing that
he doesn't really have personal
knowledge because they kept the shades
drawn so he doesn't have a visual
confirmation of what was going on what
he does is that he heard what was going
on behind closed doors he was using some
form of electronic surveillance to hear
what was going on in the bedroom unless
of course they were engaging in conduct
so loudly that he was able to hear that
without the aid of an electronic device
but let's assume for the moment that
this is a fairly sophisticated private
investigator and he's using electronic
surveillance equipment if that's the
case then he doesn't have personal
knowledge except for what is on this
videotape now California not only has
very strict invasion of privacy laws but
California also has very strict
electronic surveillance laws and
California is a two-party consent state
which means you need to have consent
from all of the parties to a
conversation before you're allowed to
electronically surveil them so you can't
just pick up the phone and start
recording you need to actually get
consent from the
person that's on the line in that
telephone and electronically surveilling
someone in their own house might be a
violation of that electronic
surveillance wiretapping law which I
think would really preclude this
particular evidence
so if lecture read really should have
objected on multiple grounds right now
to prevent this kind of testimony from
coming in it might be an invasion of
privacy it might be a violation of the
electronic surveillance act and there's
very little chance of that mrs. Cole
consented to this recording so those are
all very good reasons by statute that
this evidence might not come in okay
there's also a huge hearsay problem and
I just live for good hearsay questions
the tape itself is hearsay and arguably
what is being said on this tape is also
hearsay so there is a double hearsay
problem now you can get over double
hearsay by showing an exception or an
exemption at both levels but because
there's hearsay in what's being said and
hearsay in the form of the tape you have
to have an argument for both of those
levels before testimony like this
evidence like this can come in so let's
talk about the first level of hearsay in
the tape itself now just because you
have a recording does not mean that it's
not hearsay on the contrary it is still
an out-of-court statement a document can
be hearsay a videotape can be hearsay
and an audio tape like this can
definitely be hearsay so I think the
easiest way to get around this hearsay
problem is to establish from the private
investigator that this is a business
record he is essentially in the business
of creating audio tapes exactly like
this that he has done it many times
before and then lay the elements of the
business records exception that he is a
custodian for this particular audio tape
if not the creator of this audio tape
and that it was formed in the regular
course of business and just go over the
different grounds for the business
records exception so
assume that he's able to get over the
first level of hearsay in the audio tape
itself I think that there is a
presumption that emails and actual
recordings tend to be pretty reliable
so courts try to bend over backwards to
get those kind of records in so we get
to the second layer of hearsay and
here's where it gets really interesting
you might say that what is going on in
this tape their out-of-court statements
and therefore they should be considered
hearsay and excludable from evidence but
remember that hearsay is not just any
statement it is a statement used to
prove the truth of the matter asserted
now no one is using this tape for the
veracity of what is actually being said
on the tape in other words that her
gentleman caller is actually better in
bed than her husband or that God exists
because she keeps saying oh god oh god
instead what they are doing is showing
the existence of the underlying acts in
other words that she committed adultery
and these exclamations are evidence of
engaging in that act which has legal
significance under the prenuptial
agreement so I don't think this actually
qualifies as hearsay because hearsay
must be a statement used for the truth
of the matter asserted they're not using
it for the truth of the matter asserted
and therefore we don't even have to talk
about whether it's an exception to the
hearsay rule I don't think it qualifies
as hearsay in the first instance
now that being said I think Fletcher
Reed really should be objecting here
because he needs to break this up he
needs to try to prevent this tape from
coming into evidence and he's just
allowed the other attorney to play it
whenever she wants and establish its
credibility he might lose these hearsay
objections because it probably gets in
under the first level and is probably
not even hearsay on the second level but
still you got an object you've got to
preserve the record to show that you
objected so that you can make that
argument on appeal and you've got to
break up the flow of the direct
examination not good lawyer by Fletcher
Reed here your honor and why is that mr.
Reed because it's devastating to my case
overruled
good call not a valid objection and the
judge was right to overrule it
Your Honor with the court be willing to
grant me a short bathroom break can't it
wait
yes it can't but I've heard that if you
hold it you can damage the prostate
gland making it very difficult to get an
erection or even become aroused is that
true it has to be in that case I better
take a little break myself you know I
was going to object and say that this is
a conversation that really should take
place during a sidebar but then it
occurred to me that there is no jury so
there's no reason to have a sidebar a
sidebar is only for when you want
something to be talked about outside of
the presence of the jury and since there
is no jury here there's no reason to
have a sidebar examinations are gonna
take hours if not days especially a
witness as important as this private
investigator you've got to lay really
really specific foundation which they
haven't done here so it wouldn't be
surprising for the attorney to ask for a
short recess before starting into their
cross-examination of one of the most
important witnesses of the entire trial
[Music]
the hell are you doing flutter Reed is
really gonna need a new suit after this
if you need a new suit check out the
links in the description below it's
where I get all my suits and it helps
out the channel under the circumstances
I have no choice but to recess this case
until 9:00 a.m. tomorrow morning unless
of course you feel you can still proceed
so in reality if someone really had been
beaten up in the middle of trial
everything would stop there would
basically be a manhunt going on in this
courthouse the judge would never just
ask if Fletcher Reed was ready to
continue because there would be police
swarming all over the place maybe the
SWAT team was called in there's gonna be
an investigation and they need to find
this horrible person that presumably
beat the hell out of Fletcher Reed so
this trial would not continue on the
same day at all it would stop
immediately
hello so you actually have to be really
careful when you bring cell phones in
the court some courthouses allow it but
others like the federal courthouse in
Virginia that proceeded over the mana
Ford case don't allow any cell phones
whatsoever and they don't even have
cubbies or safes to lock up your cell
phone when you get there so if you
arrive in court you're forced to get rid
of your cell phone or find some other
place off premises to store it god help
you if your cell phone goes off and the
judge hears it
I have seen people expelled from court
specifically for violating a rule like
that judges can be really really
persnickety when it comes to electronic
devices and things going off in their
courtroom so you got to be very careful
respondent calls kenneth Falk I think
that's right to call them the respondent
this is not a situation where you'd have
plaintiff and defendant I think it would
be claimant and respondent which is a
nice little touch to get that
terminology right I think that's that's
correct
don't do it don't enter the well do you
know my client Samantha Cole yes
okay good question establish it
open-ended good job isn't it true that
your relationship with my client is
entirely platonic I object your honor
to yourself but I would like to rephrase
the question that was actually a good
objection he asked a leading question of
this witness and if he hadn't objected
the other attorney should have because
you're not allowed to lead your own
witness this is direct examination all
your questions have to be open-ended so
when he asked isn't it true that you've
never blah blah blah that was improper
that question implied only one answer
and that's exactly what you're not
allowed to do on direct examination so
good objection and good striking of the
record
sex with her every time you mad didn't
you did you fire he's badgering the
witness so I probably don't need to tell
you that there's all kinds of things
that are wrong here number one he's
asking tons of leading questions he is
badgering the witness like crazy he is
asking argumentative questions just
because he has called this witness
doesn't mean that he is allowed to
engage in that kind of behavior that's
totally unprofessional and it's really
probably a violation of your duty of
loyalty to your clients so despite him
being honest he is still breaking his
ethical rules to his client so what he
really needs to do was just shut up and
not say anything that way he can both
tell the truth and also uphold his
ethical obligations to his client no
questions yeah exactly right when you
don't need to gild the lily you don't
need to get anything else out of the
witness you do not ask any questions you
do not ask any follow-up you just let
the record remain where it is so that
the other side doesn't have an
opportunity to have a rebuttal or to do
damage control of what they have already
done you just let sleeping dogs lie and
you move on so great job by this other
attorney of your driver's license not
allowed to enter the well like that the
bailiff will tackle you no tell me what
it says here on your birth certificate
under date of what does this have to do
with anything
Oh rule none of this stuff is in
evidence yet you have to add this to the
evidence before you're allowed to talk
about it you just need to establish that
a material fact is more or less likely
to be true based on the presence of this
evidence or testimony so that's a very
very low bar so in reality if the judge
didn't really know where Fletcher Reed
was going with this argument then what
the judge would do is ask
Fletcher Reed to make a proffer he would
not just say I have no idea what's going
to happen so I'm just going to allow
this evidence to come in the idea that
you're gonna sandbag everyone including
the judge and the other side it rarely
happens in real life there's so much
briefing and there's so much
back-and-forth that you have an idea of
what arguments are going to be made
ahead of time it's not just sprung on
you and your client like it is in this
movie she was only 17 when she got
married which makes her a minor and in
the great state of California no minor
can enter into any legal contract
without parental consent
including prenuptial agreements this
contract is voidable my client has been
written more than Seattle Slew is
entitled half of the maybe three nine
five million dollars Jordan is not the
game nothing further your honor
all right let's talk about marriage law
last time I covered this scene just in
isolation I pointed out that in
California a minor can enter into a
contract when they are still a minor
that that contract becomes voidable at
the option of the minor who can then
ratify or disclaim that contract when
they get to the age of majority which is
the age of 18 in California so as a
technical matter the contract is not
void ab initio in other words it's not
void from the very beginning of the
contract it is voidable at the option of
the minor but that is not the end of the
question now it's time to think like a
lawyer
[Music]
so the respondent argues that the
prenuptial agreement is voidable and
she's exercising her option to avoid it
all right so what does the other side
say well this is not the end of the game
this is actually the very beginning what
the husband would probably argue as a
couple of things number one a contract
can be ratified without an express or in
other words the actual language of
ratification you can ratify a contract
by your conduct so the husband would
argue that for the last thirteen years
this woman has been in the marriage has
received all the benefits of the
marriage and therefore has ratified the
prenuptial agreement that she entered
into when she was a minor furthermore I
think the husband would also argue that
the defense of fraud applies this woman
without notifying the husband or fiance
at that time fraudulently stated that
she was of the age to enter into a
marriage and a marriage contract so she
committed a fraud on the marriage and on
the husband so he would have the burden
to establish that a frog was committed
and that that is a defense to the lack
of contract formation that she's arguing
I think he would be likely to win that
defense that that affirmative defense
now the last time I covered this
specific seen a lot of astute viewers
pointed out that well if the prenuptial
agreement is void that doesn't that mean
that the entire marriage is void from
the very beginning because the same
fraud that precludes the prenuptial
agreement from being effective would
prevent the marriage itself from being
affected well that is a very very
interesting question but that probably
doesn't change the result and here's why
in California there's no such thing as
common-law marriage but what there is is
something called a Marvin claim you
might have heard of this as palimony in
other words just because you are able to
show that a marriage is invalid there is
still a claim to be made for essentially
exactly the same rights you would have
if you had entered into a marriage and
the the Marvin claim dates back to
it's the 70s it's named after the actor
Lee Marvin who had a seven-year
relationship with a woman and they
didn't get married but the court found
that even in the absence of a marriage
they that the equities required some
division of assets along the lines of
what would be given under a marriage I
think the equities in this particular
case show that there is something that's
like a marriage and in that circumstance
the marriage rules would kick in and you
would still need to decide how those
marital assets are divided up California
is a community property state it is also
a no-fault divorce state which means
that in general it doesn't matter who
has engaged in adultery either party is
allowed to exit the marriage whenever
they want and if there is no prenuptial
agreement then community property
applies and there's more or less an even
division of those assets that exist in
the marital form but to tie this all
together I think all the equities go to
the husband and that's something that
courts really do take a look at even if
you have good arguments on either side
and there's no clear answer the courts
will look to the equities and hear the
the wife has committed a fraud on the
marriage she's the one that committed
the adultery in violation of the
prenuptial agreement and I think that
the court is likely to take all of that
into consideration probably find that
she has ratified the contract or that
the affirmative defense of fraud applies
I think the husband probably wins here
but if you disagree if there are any
family law lawyers in the audience let
me know in the comments below I would
love to continue this discussion and by
the way if this makes your head spin
it's you and me both these are the kinds
of gray areas that we get into in the
law all the time and that's why you
often need to hire a lawyer to handle
these kinds of things because it gets
really really messy in light of this new
evidence the court must rule in favor of
mrs. Cole she is hereby awarded half in
America
again the judge would never just blurt
out in the middle of the trial
proceedings that one side has won as it
entitled to whatever it is that they're
asking for not all the witnesses have
been called the parties haven't
conducted their closing arguments they
haven't filed their post trial briefs
they haven't made their post trial
motions there are a million things that
need to happen between now and when the
judge renders his final verdict
including giving a tentative decision
and allowing the the parties to talk
about that final decision probably
calling for another settlement
conference no way would the judge ever
just bang his gavel and say you win
responded not gonna happen what if I
just won 11 million dollars hey I'm the
victim here you said it yourself now I'm
gonna hit him where it hurts
well mr. Riebe do we have an agreement
on custody or not I think here Fletcher
Reed needs to follow the wishes of his
client and reject the settlement offer
although this would again happen in
settlement negotiations outside of right
in front of the judge after having
handed down a verdict in this case
but if he finds himself ethically unable
to make the argument that she wants to
make then he can withdraw from counsel
he can talk about irreconcilable
differences between him and his client
and make a motion to withdraw as her
first divorce attorney has already done
in this case she can she's not in a bad
spot she can get another counselor to
help with the this post trial briefing
in this post trial custody dispute so it
wouldn't really be much prejudice to her
I don't think the judge has the power to
issue a contempt ruling when courts not
in session this is after the the trial
has happened I'm not sure he has that
power
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now it's time to give liar liar a grade
for legal realism now there's a lot
going against it unrealistic dialog
supernatural elements totally
unrealistic trial timeline but I have to
admit it was a ton of fun to try and
untangle this legal web involving the
prenup and a minor entering into a
contract good job by the writers so I
give liar a liar the benefit of the
doubt and I give it another B+ not bad
good job guys
do you agree with that grade leave your
objections in the comments below and let
me know what I should review next in the
meantime check out this playlist that
includes all of my prior reactions
including suits better call Saul and
tons more so click on the playlist and
I'll see you in court